c'était une palette plein un cube plein
de caisses de munitions vu jamais vu
depuis le début de la cré du coronavirus
le propriétaire du pavillon chasse et
pêche fait des affaires d'or
fermé depuis mercredi il continue
néanmoins les ventes en ligne ou par
téléphone et ça ne dérougit pas c'est ce
que changer le plus c'est les gens qui
n'ont pas de permis de positions
d'acquisition d'armes à feu qu'ils
connaissent absolument rien fait qui
veulent des hommes qui évoluent l'eau
les gens sont un petit peu en mode
panique l'avait que le kof 19 j'imagine
en ces temps là aussi j'ai vu surtout au
foie ce serait beaucoup
puis l'eau c'est à tous les jours tous
les marchands d'armes que nous avons
contactés ont remarqué une hausse
importante des ventes depuis le début de
la pandémie
plusieurs types de munitions sont même
en rupture de stock
peut-être certains certaines personnes
ont des scénarios post apocalyptique en
tête mais l'idée c'est qu'on stocke ce
genre de choses là un peu comme mon
stock la nourriture et tout au corps ou
le per est vrai et ce sont des discours
des idées circulent beaucoup en ligne
[Musique]
certains amateurs de chasse ou de tir
sportif ont aussi peur que la production
soit affectés par la pandémie et la
fermeture de la frontière parce que de
nombreux manufacturiers sont aux etats
unis c'est sûr que moi j'étais dans
certains magasins le championnat pour
faire des achats et munitions mais ça
c'est fluide et complètement alors que
la grande majorité des titres boursiers
chutent depuis le début de la crise les
codes de plusieurs compagnies d'armes à
feu sont onze ici simon couture radio
canada granby